a NATO military leader is raising new
concerns this morning about Russia's
massive military exercise underway in
Eastern Europe
the head of NATO's Military Committee
says the war games could be a serious
suit could be as seen serious a surge
preparation for a big war despite
Russian assurances they pose no threat
the week-long exercise has taken place
in areas near the Baltic Sea involves
thousands of personnel tanks and
aircraft Elizabeth Palmer is near Saint
Petersburg Russia she's on the ground
with Russian troops good morning these
exercises are certainly a real workout
for the various branches of the Russian
Armed Forces but they're also intended
as spectacle with the pictures of the
action intended for broadcast around the
world the message especially to the US
and its NATO allies is taking on Russia
would be a mistake NATO is watching
carefully it says as many as a hundred
thousand Russian and Belarusian troops
are taking part
the Russians say that's nonsense there
are only just under 13,000 the truth
lies probably somewhere in the middle
but the lack of transparency adds to the
threatening tone Russia stages huge
military exercises every four years but
this one is exceptional because part of
it is taking place in neighboring
Belarus to the west which puts those
thousands of troops
nose-to-nose against NATO forces just
across the border for CBS this morning
I'm Elizabeth Palmer in luga south of
st. Petersburg